しばらく帽子をかぶります。
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです！
みなさんはされ･･･
みなさんはされて嫌なことありますか？
まあワシが今までやられてきたことでちょっと嫌なことって何かあったかなって考えたんですけど
あれは俺がねもう小学生ぐらいの時だった
俺が何かを喋るとその喋ったことをずっと真似する先輩がいたんですよ。
はじめしゃちょー「先輩！」
先輩「先輩！」
はじめしゃちょー「えっ？」
先輩「えっ？」
はじめしゃちょー「何？」
先輩「何？」
はじめしゃちょー「やめてくださいよ！」
先輩「やめてくださいよ！」
はじめしゃちょー「ねえ！！！」
先輩「ねえ！！！」
はじめしゃちょー「ちょっと！！！」
先輩「ちょっと！！！」
はじめしゃちょー「もお～～！！！」
先輩「もお～～～～～～！！！」
みなさんこういう経験ありませんでしたか？
昔こんなバカげたことする先輩がいたんすよ今会ったらもう顔面ブン殴
ワシは気になったことがあるんですけども、この相手の言ったことをリピートする奴はですね
いずれ終わるんですよ
俺の時もね先輩が最後「あ～、ごめんごめん！」みたいな感じで、
あの途中で打ち切られたんですけども。
もしこれを打ち切らずに永遠にね、
あるターゲットの言ってることをリピートし続けたら
ターゲットはどうなるか？というちょっと
検証をしてみようと思います。
今からタイの留学生のナム君が家に押しかけて来るんですけども、
そのナム君をターゲットにして
もう彼が喋ったことを僕が全部全く繰り返します。
もう本当に無情ですよ
もう何があっても僕はナム君の言うこと喋りますから
それ続けた結果最終的にターゲットはどうなるのか？という実験をしてみようと思います。
では行こう！
はじめしゃちょー「A+に下がった」
ナム君「あ～あ」
ナム君「すげえ」
はじめしゃちょー「最初はグー！じゃんけんポン！」
ナム君「ちょっと待って待って待って･･･」
はじめしゃちょー「あああ～～～～！も～～～」
ナム君「ありがとうございます」
はじめしゃちょー「もう知らね！楽しくな～～～～い！」
はじめしゃちょー「待って、俺動画編集しなきゃ･･･」
ナム君「何？」
はじめしゃちょー「何？」
ナム君「あ、そうだ、動画編集すんじゃん」
はじめしゃちょー「あ、そうだ、動画編集すんじゃん」
ナム君「何？」
はじめしゃちょー「何？」
ナム君「やだも～～～～～！」
はじめしゃちょー「やだも～～～～～！」
ナム君「何？」
はじめしゃちょー「何？」
ナム君「ああ･･･」
はじめしゃちょー「ああ･･･」
ナム君「助けて･･･」
はじめしゃちょー「助けて･･･」
ナム君「ね～え」
はじめしゃちょー「ね～え」
ナム君「なんで？！」
はじめしゃちょー「なんで？！」
ナム君「あっはっはっは」
はじめしゃちょー「あっはっはっは」
ナム君「んっはっは」
はじめしゃちょー「あっはっは」
ナム君「疲れた」
はじめしゃちょー「うん、疲れた」
ナム君「ね～え」
はじめしゃちょー「ね～え」
ナム君「違うじゃん」
はじめしゃちょー「違うじゃん」
ナム君「それは」
はじめしゃちょー「それは」
ナム君「だから何？」
はじめしゃちょー「だから何？」
ナム君「何？」
はじめしゃちょー「何？」
ナム君「助けて～」
はじめしゃちょー「助けて～」
ナム君「ね～え」
はじめしゃちょー「ね～え」
ナム君「動画編集しないといけない」
はじめしゃちょー「動画編集しないと･･･」
ナム君「ほら」
はじめしゃちょー「ほら」
ナム君「あっはっは」
はじめしゃちょー「あっはっは」
ナム君「まじ」
はじめしゃちょー「まじ」
ナム君「ねえ」
はじめしゃちょー「ねえ」
ナム君「ちょっとオーバーじゃない？」
はじめしゃちょー「ちょっとオーバーじゃない？」
ナム君「オーバーだよ」
はじめしゃちょー「オーバーだよ」
ナム君「違うよ」
はじめしゃちょー「違うよ」
ナム君「違くないよ」
はじめしゃちょー「違くないよ」
ナム君「違う」
はじめしゃちょー「違う」
ナム君「ね～え」
はじめしゃちょー「ね～え」
ナム君「何～～？」
はじめしゃちょー「もう何～～～もう何もう」
ナム君「もう無理もう～～～」
「「ああああ～～～～～～～～～！！！！！！！」」
ナム君「もう、そんなんじゃないよ～･･･」
はじめしゃちょー「もう、そんなんじゃないよ～･･･」
「「ふああ～～～～～～～～～～～～～」」
ナム君「完璧」
はじめしゃちょー「完璧」
ナム君「完璧です」
はじめしゃちょー「完璧です」
ナム君「わりかし適当じゃない？」
はじめしゃちょー「わりかし適当じゃない？」
ナム君「ああ」
はじめしゃちょー「ああ」
ナム君「死ぬ」
はじめしゃちょー「死ぬ」
ナム君「無理」
はじめしゃちょー「無理」
ナム君「ああ」
はじめしゃちょー「ああ」
ナム君「何？」
はじめしゃちょー「何？」
ナム君「駄目だよ」
はじめしゃちょー「駄目だよ」
ナム君「もう無理だ」
はじめしゃちょー「もう無理だ」
ナム君「よし」
はじめしゃちょー「よし」
はじめしゃちょー「結果はまあ寝るということでした。」
はじめしゃちょー「どうでしたか？ナム君」
ナム君「頭おかしくなるっても～～ほんとにも～～」
はじめしゃちょー「本当頭がおかしくなるぐらいイラつくんで」
ナム君「ほんとに･･･」
はじめしゃちょー「ほんとに･･･」
はじめしゃちょー「やばい」
ナム君「やばい」
はじめしゃちょー「やばかった？」
ナム君「ああ」
はじめしゃちょー「ああ」
「「もういい～！！！！！」」